[Musik]
jetzt live aus köln der presseclub mit
jörg schönenborn
presseclub an diesem sonntagmittag
erstens kommt es anders zweitens als man
denkt in demnächst bücher über dieses
wahljahr geschrieben werden könnte das
ein guter titel sein erinnern sie sich
noch rund um ostern als ist nur eine
frage der zeit zu sein schien bis söder
auch in der cdu die rückendeckung hat
und kanzlerkandidat wird oder anfang mai
als annalena baerbock nach glänzendem
start zum höhenflug ansetzte vor das
ganze dann wie ein soufflé zusammenfiel
erinnern sie sich an die vorwürfe armin
laschet fahre im schlafwagen ins
kanzleramt er verweigere den wahlkampf
paletten gar nicht nötig habe und dann
kam der große sommerregen und ein
unglückliches lachen und dann begann der
rautenförmige aufstieg des olaf scholz
und jetzt passiert noch was in den
letzten tagen kommt alles doch noch
anders oder so wie man denkt unser
presseclub heute wahl krimi wer macht
das rennen und ich freue mich auf diese
gäste stefan aus des bei uns herausgeber
der welt herzlich willkommen ich freue
mich auf albrecht von lucke redakteur
bei den blättern für deutsche und
internationale politik herzlich
willkommen jana hensel autorin für zeit
und zeit online und melanie amann ist
bei uns co leiterin des hauptstadtbüros
des spiegels und dort auch mitglied der
chefredaktion
da frage man eine einstiegs runde zu
dieser frage kommt es anders als man
denkt was erwarten sie ich finde das
rennen ist moment offen wie selten bei
anderen bundestagswahlen erlebt habe
also ich halte schon für möglich dass
armin laschet vielleicht noch den
schlussspurt hinlegt und es schafft
scholz abzuhängen also es kann wirklich
eine überraschung geben am wahlabend und
ich weiß gab auch ein bisschen skepsis
bezüglich der umfragen insgesamt obmann
denen neben klaren vorsprung von scholl
zutrauen kann
das ist tatsächlich eine große frage
inwieweit die prognosen sich am ende
bewahrheiten ich glaube aber freier mann
das die wahl gelaufen ist wir wissen
nicht wie weit der abstand zwischen
stolz und laschet sein wird aber er
liegt in den persönlichkeits werten den
persönlichkeits werten so weit vorne und
das ich glaube die deutschen wollen im
kanzleramt sehen laschet wird auf 100 es
wird nicht reichen insofern die wahl ist
eigentlich eine woche vorher schon
gelaufen ich glaube das was an umfragen
der spd im augenblick zugerechnet wird
also und 25 das wird ein treffen
ich glaube die werden da ungefähr liegen
ich glaube die cdu wird noch aufholen
ich glaube weil viele unentschlossene
die was vielleicht laschet nicht so doll
und überzeugend fanden dass die im
endeffekt wenn sie in die wahlkabine
gehen oder wenn sie die fähren im brief
wahlzettel ausfüllen sich auf ihre
eigenen interessenlage besinnen und sich
dann überlegen dass wir nicht doch nach
acht ich hab immer cdu gewählt das mache
ich jetzt auch weiter das problem und
das interessante wird sein aber darüber
könne vielleicht ein händler sprechen
das natürlich diejenigen die afg wählen
in wirklichkeit eine rot grüne koalition
bestimmte unterstützen oder guten rot
rot rot rot grüne gute these land müssen
wir jetzt andere vergleichen kann falls
es erläutern müssen genau herr van look
kommt eine wende oder haben wir quasi
schon eine ahnung wie es ausgeht ich
würde herrn aus zustimmen ich glaube die
cdu/csu kann auch an boden gut machen
aber sie fragten am anfang kommt es
anders als man denkt gemessen daran ist
das was armin laschet jetzt versucht nur
noch das allerschlimmste zu verhindern
er wird das mit abstand schlechteste
ergebnis der cdu csu in der gesamten
bundesrepublik englischen geschichte
einfahren schlechter als konrad adenauer
am anfang 249 und das vor dem
hintergrund dass er noch vor einem jahr
ein abstand von über 20 prozent zu auf
scholz hat also vor dem hintergrund
haben cdu csu ausdrücklich auch die csu
gerade dessen ob der tatsache dessen was
in den letzten wochen passiert ist die
wahl eigentlich schon verloren es geht
nur noch darum mit einem vielleicht mit
einer nasenlänge als erster ins ziel zu
kommen und danach wird natürlich die
große frage losgehen und auch das wetzen
die messer was das bedeutet aber die
niederlage der cdu csu steht eigentlich
jetzt schon fest weil das was eigentlich
hätte normal sein müssen ein klarer
weise über 30 prozent absolut verspielt
wurde ok danke danke dass ich so
prognose aber das letzte land das
schlechteste wahlergebnis hat die cdu
schon seit vielen jahren bei vielen seit
wochen war das hat mir mal wieder
eingefahren das hat einmal
noch einmal zu einem scheinriesen
geworden herr von lucke sie war schon
davor in der krise insofern sozusagen
die fallhöhe die sie jetzt für herrn
laschet errichten halte ich für ein
bisschen groß gleichwohl kann man ihnen
widersprechen dass der wahlkampf für ihn
schlecht gelaufen ist aber erinnern sie
sich an die zahlen von for coronary top
four hensel die zahlen vor wonach sie
können sich genau angucken die cdu/csu
stand für sie eben wirklich bewusst
machen dass ist auch das bringt was
danach bin ja auf ihre zahlen diesmal so
gespannt der schönbrunn wie noch nie das
ist ein einer wir werden ein einschlag
erleben wer nicht gar müssen so vor
allem eines bewusst machen es ist das
erste mal seit
2005 dass wir wieder eine echte wahl
haben steinmeier steinbrück schulz waren
alles kampagnen die sich im vorfeld
erledigt hatten das ist übrigens auch
der grund warum am tag eine ungeheure um
sich hat die sicherung bei der spd die
spd kann ihrem glück kaum trauen und
frau hensel die mögen recht haben
umfragen sind immer volatil sie waren
aber wie gesagt wo sie sich an vor einem
jahr noch bei 38 prozent für die cdu csu
im sommer 2010 40 prozent selbst im
frühjahr noch deutlich über 30 prozent
und am schluss dass doch der witz vorher
so zählen natürlich die wahl zahlen und
da wird es klar unter 30 prozent sein
sein das schlechteste ergebnis war
bekanntlich das von das
zweitschlechteste von angela merkel dass
beim letzten mal als 33 prozent und dem
anfangsjahr der republik 31 prozent von
konrad adenauer bei elf parteien die im
bundestag danach waren genug der reis
das ist einer starken serie
gesagt die kann genügen der zahlenspiele
bevor ich vermag einer schlagzeile
dieser woche komme einfach eine
bemerkung die mir immer wichtig ist
umfragen zumindest die die ard zuletzt
jetzt veröffentlicht hat am donnerstag
sind eine momentaufnahme und haben
überhaupt nicht die absicht
vorauszuschauen was bis zum wahltag noch
passiert also insofern meine persönliche
meinung es wäre ein statistisches wunder
wenn die wahl genauso ausgänge wie es
umfragen sieben oder zehn tage vorher
als aktuelle stimmung gemessen haben
aber das nur als persönlicher einschub
freimann eine schlagzeile dieser woche
ist eine von der staatsanwaltschaft in
osnabrück initiiert durchsuchung im
bundesfinanzministerium die liegt schon
länger zurück hat aber diese woche die
debatte um olaf scholz und auch seine
aussagen zu früheren finanzaffären
wieder in den blick geraten lassen ist
das etwas was die wahl entscheidend was
in den letzten tagen noch eine rolle
spielen kann es ist also wenn man meine
theorie folgt dass der abstand kleiner
sein könnte und sich womöglich noch
komplett erledigt zwischen union und spd
ist das natürlich schon für olaf scholz
ein gewaltiger
eine gewaltige bürde oder ein so man
sagen ein mühlstein der eben da jetzt
noch am bein hängt weil es ja auch ein
zeit auf seinen versuch sich dieses
image des saubermanns und das bei uns
gibt es nichts sozusagen zu monieren und
meine arbeit als finanzminister ist
qualifiziert mich in perfekter weise für
den top job es gibt aber natürlich auch
einige merkwürdigkeiten bei dieser
durchsuchung ich möchte jetzt nicht hier
alles aufdröseln aber wenn man eben die
politischen verhältnisse in
niedersachsen an sie die personen die
dort involviert sind die die an dieser
durchsuchung beteiligt waren die sie
beantragt haben die sie auch genehmigt
haben auch der richter ist ja eher aus
dem cdu milieu wie es scheint und also
ich glaube zwar nicht dass da ein
komplott jetzt irgendwie gegen herrn
scholz geschmiedet wurde aber es wurde
sicher auch billigend in kauf genommen
was das für eine außenwirkung hat
ich finde das ist eine ziemlich schräge
geschichte muss man wirklich sagen und
wenn man sich die personen ansieht und
wenn man sich ansieht wer daran
beteiligt war und mit welchen gründen
man diese durchsuchungsaktion
organisiert hat hat man den eindruck da
steckt ein politischer plan dahinter ich
will nicht sagen von ganz oben das ist
nicht die frage aber ich glaube
diejenigen die daran beteiligt waren
hatten schon irgend etwas im sinn das
wäre nicht nötig gewesen und die art wie
das vor sich gegangen ist ist eigentlich
nicht so wie man sich eine normale
juristische angelegenheit vorstellen die
auch die justizministerin von
niedersachsen und kommt aus osnabrück
die ist da sehr lange gewesen die können
sich alle sehr gut es gibt eine menge
persönlicher kontakte die müssen nicht
unbedingt einen kausalen charakter haben
aber ich finde das ziemlich verdächtig
ehrlich gesagt also ich hab so was darf
man die anlagen verso ist ja ein ganz
gut in den kram drin deswegen gab und
also die die ermittler kann ja auch
gründe nennen die staatsanwaltschaft
auch wenn das ja sehr ausführlich jetzt
auch in unserem jüngsten bericht
aufgearbeitet aber es ist schon so dass
denke ich für alle beteiligten das ganz
praktisch war dass diese durchsuchen
jetzt
ende darum an die große glocke zu hängen
an welchen affären scholz irgendwie auf
irgendeine weise beteiligt ist das
produkt die ganze sache gelernt finde
ich eher skandale müssen sich
skandale müssen sich im echtzeit
vollziehen um wirkung zu
zu haben um sozusagen drama zu
initiieren der lacher von laschet hat
als skandal funktioniert obwohl
vergleichsweise klein ist aber hat in
echtzeit statt gefunden genauso wie die
stolper reihen von frau bär burg die
versuche von charles die alten skandale
auf zu haben das funktioniert eben nicht
wir sind in einem bewerbungsprozess
bundestagswahl sind im prinzip
bewerbungsrunde für drei kandidaten und
ich glaube dass die meisten leute
glauben er wäre kann einmal kandidat
geworden ist der kann im prinzip mit
alten affären nicht mehr wirklich
beschädigt werden im gegenteil die leute
sind überrascht dass parteien sich für
kandidaten entscheiden die sich dann als
sohn tauglich erweisen das ist ja die
eigentliche dynamik im wahlkampf nicht
die alten skandale haben gewirkt sondern
die doch vielzahl an neuen skandal die
völlig unterschiedlich sind und am ende
armin laschet und annalena baerbock
quasi aus dem feld geräumt haben könnte
man ja sogar sagen sie sehen den
presseclub im fernsehen sie hören im
radio aber wer streamen wie jede woche
natürlich in den sozialen netzwerken und
der tagesschau und presseclub und ich
lese viele ihrer rückmeldungen gehe auch
gleich darauf ein freue mich dafür danke
für die kommentare
wir sind ja in der diskussion darüber
was könnte den
aus sicht des frühjahrs sehr
überraschenden vorsprung der spd
stabilisieren oder verändern wir haben
kurz die durchsuchung im
finanzministerium angesprochen ein
argument das die union im moment am
stärksten anführt ist ja die warnung vor
einer regierung aus spd grünen und
linken haben laschet auf dem
csu-parteitag ist ein paar tage her aber
das ist die melodie im moment immer
wieder intoniert wird
ich frage mich der satz ist ja relativ
einfach wir koalieren nicht mit der
linken wir bekämpfen die afg und die
recht und die soll verschwindet ist
eigentlich ein relativ einfacher satz
warum bringt olaf scholz das nicht auf
die beine diesen satz auszusprechen weil
er sich eine hintertür offenhalten will
und diese hintertür müssen wir
verschließen durch ein gutes
wahlergebnis für die union und dafür
müssen wir kämpfen
hamburg ist eine frage die auch
userinnen und user beschäftigt kann es
zu rot rot grün kommen oder anders
gefragt barbara scholz nicht nein das
mache ich nicht es wird rechnerisch so
sieht es jedenfalls aus dazu kommen
können ich halte es aber für völlig
ausgeschlossen
scholz hat natürlich aber das macht ihn
auch wirklich angreifbar ein grund warum
er und das halte ich weniger in der
logik des druck potenzials danach für
den grund sondern ich glaube der grund
der ihn dazu bewegt das erstens einen
beschluss des parteitages und das wissen
dass erhebliche teile seiner eigenen
partei insbesondere die jusos durchaus
affinitäten haben das sind ja nicht
kleine teile die aussagen durchaus zu
recht auf grund der schnittmengen im
innenpolitischen bereich
sozialpolitischen bereich das wäre
eigentlich in dieser hinsicht die
logische konsequenz scholz ist kein
kandidat der danach aber jemals eine rot
rot grüne koalition eingehen würde er
ist und das ist das interessante er
nicht so sicher er ist dynamisch so
kontrollieren kann dabei wenn er erstmal
sondierung eine vorstellung dass alles
super zusammen dann wie vorstellungen
nämlich vorstellung die erstens wird die
frage sein ob ein sondierung eintritt
die zweite frage wird sein ob die
linkspartei überhaupt geeignet ist das
was sie jetzt macht sie hübsch sich doch
jetzt gewaltig auf die linkspartei hat
erkannt dass die einzige möglichkeit in
einem stadium wo sie bei 56 prozent
steht die einzige möglichkeit darin
besteht sich selber einen neuen
gebrauchswert zu verleihen ich zu sagen
wir sind jetzt zu jeder regierung
bereiten das ist die logik der
linkspartei da ist sogar frau wissler
bereit das zu tun obwohl sie davor
dezidiert über jahre eine gegenposition
verlustangst unter die
fünf-prozent-hürde zu absolut ein ganz
entscheidender grund es ist schließt
jetzt auch die reihen da das müssen uns
bewusst machen es ist über jahre nichts
passiert in der kommunikation zwischen
linken spd und grünen nichts weil
natürlich und das war die logik auch
diese koalition ihre im raum war die
grünen sind das kommt noch eine viel
tiefere verletzungen die rings da liegen
die grünen sind seit jahren quasi von
der linkspartei als polizisten vor sich
hin die aversion des mosaiks treisberg
sei dafür alle alle sehr latinum schon
absolut absolut dass die aversion ist
seitens der grünen noch weit größer als
bei der spd und von daher ist diese
frage entscheiden punkt sagen einer der
vielleicht wirklich auf den punkt von
von von scholz führt scholz gewinnt
diese wahl so denn das stimmt vielleicht
gewinnt er sie nicht aber er hat diesen
erfolg ja nicht dadurch erzielen das ist
auch das entscheidende ja eine
revolution angekündigt hätte oder gar
eine erneuerung mit rot-rot-grün scholz
und das ist das meisterstück er ist der
mann der stabilität weil sie laute sie
kritisiert den gedanken fest das wäre
mein nächstes thema aber freiland ist
ihnen schon ins wort gefallen weil sie
eine andere vermutung hat was katrin
rohde angeht ja also ich meine also
erstmal bekommen ja von herrn laschet
ursprünglich und seiner aussage und dem
parlament und der frage ob das was
drehen kann es ist der versuch und den
sehen wir interessanterweise bei den
grünen auch die leute im prinzip mit
angst botschaften zu sich zu treiben es
ist ja immer schlecht wenn du als partei
oder als kandidat sagst welt uns bevor
die anderen am ende eine koalition
machen und die grünen machen das auf
andere weise sie sagenwelt uns oder die
welt geht unter da in diesem jüngsten
wahlkampfspot von annalena baerbock die
nächste regierung ist die letzte
regierung die noch irgendetwas tun kann
um den klimawandel auf sein das ist ja
auch eine angst botschaft im prinzip nur
welt uns oder die apokalypse steht vor
der tür das ist immer finde ich so die
schwächere strategie wenn man eigentlich
nicht für sich selber im positiven sinne
wirkt aber was die machbarkeit von
rot-rot-grün angeht ich glaube es ist
ein ganz gefährliches spiel von scholz
was er da macht weil er hat ein starkes
linkes lager in seiner partei bis hin
zur parteispitze die es gibt eine dann
würde ich ihnen widersprechen es gibt
schon natürlich in diesen linken milieu
von grünen spd und linken natürlich
überschneidungen sympathien und man
kennt sich und die werden sich
unterhaken wenn es da zu sondierungen
kommt wenn scholz das nicht ausschließt
wird es ihm kaum gelingen auch die soll
also jetzt vor der wahl wird es ihm kaum
gelingen nach der wahl zu sagen da ich
sondiere gar nicht erst mit euch und was
ist wenn man dann da vor den kameras
steht und die linke sagt also es war
ganz toll wir haben auch gesagt werden
verzichten auf diese verzichten auf -
und die nato schaffen wir frühestens in
acht jahren ab da lassen uns also noch
ein bisschen zeit also wir geben alles
mit also fast einem jahr ins entwickeln
solcher stolz vielleicht nicht rauskommt
dann haust und bei den salat ich glaube
dass wichtig sind was im augenblick
macht und auch machen muss ist die
partei hinter sich zu versammeln und
wenn er sich jetzt hinstellen würde und
sagen würde eine rot rot grüne koalition
kommt für uns überhaupt nicht in frage
dann hat er ärger in seiner partei und
das was seine parteifreunde ja
gelegentlich sagen wer scholz wählt
wählt die spd ist der in wirklichkeit
richtig das heißt er kann keine option
ausschließen und er wird wahrscheinlich
auch taktisch was irgendwie eine drei
parteien koalition geben wird die
rot-rot-grüne koalition im raum stehen
lassen müssen
um dadurch die fdp dazu zu animieren um
das zu verhindern eine ampel koalition
zu machen das wird so seine überlegung
sein und schieben ich weiß nicht ob das
auch die überlegung von herrn lindner
ist aber wenn der das dann macht in den
in dem in der situation in der nähe man
rechnerisch eine rot rot grüne koalition
möglich ist oder sich dann in ein ampel
begibt dann ist er in großer gefahr wenn
es tatsächlich gemacht hat dass er
natürlich jederzeit unter druck gesetzt
werden kann in dieser regierung wenn
irgendwas wichtiges nicht mitmachen will
die steuererhöhungen was sich dann hat
er immer die möglichkeit dass ihm gesagt
wird ja also wissen sie was können wir
uns auch anders entscheiden und dann
haben wir immer noch die druckvolle der
rot-rot-grünen koalition deswegen wird
sich lasche wird sich lindner das glaube
ich sehr genau überlegen dass laschet im
wahlkampf natürlich versucht die leute
dazu zu kriegen dass die seine partei
wählen damit es kein rot rot grüne
koalition und keine ampel gibt ist ja
irgendwie nachvollziehbar dazu macht man
der wahlkampf drei hensel ist dran sind
dann
dürfen sie aber ich gebe ihnen noch marc
klingler auf twitter mit der genau diese
frage stellt die stefan aus gerade auch
skizziert hat also hält scholz an
rot-grün-rot fest um ein taktisches
argument verhandlungsmasse für die
handelswaren aber sie sind oft aber die
braucht er gar nicht heraus dass
anwender ist gar nicht der königsmacher
als der uns im moment verkauft wird wenn
scholz auf platz eins liegt dann wird
schon eine ampel anstreben und helena
muss beweisen dass er besser verhandeln
kann als vor vier jahren die gespräche
wieder hinwerfen wird er nicht können
insofern ist eigentlich die stärke ein
gefangener seiner eigenen geschichte und
rot-rot-grün glaube ich ist ein reines
tatsächlich parteitaktisches manöver der
cdu die medien lieben diese debatte auch
und allein deswegen wird scholz dieses
bündnis eingehen er ist damit schlicht
erpressbar wird rot rot grün ist ein
politisches bündnis das gesellschaftlich
polarisiert scholz wird
muss ein interesse daran haben das
bürgerliche lager in eine koalition
einzubinden und deswegen wird eine ampel
anstrich
unterschiedlicher als sagen ich will ein
schritt weiter gehen also sie haben es
gesagt haben unterschiedliche
einschätzungen hier am tisch ob es am
ende dazu kommen kann klar ist dass sie
hätte das hat er aus deutlich gemacht
sehr komplizierte taktische denkspielen
haben die wählerinnen und wähler glaube
ich im moment auch etwas über fordern
also wir haben ja mindestens ein drittel
die noch unentschlossen sind und die
einfach nach einer logik suchen warum
sie wie abstimmen sollen ich will aber
einen punkt aufgreifen denn sie gerade
angesprochen haben wir von lucke weil
der eindruck dass wir gleichzeitig ein
weiter so und veränderungen verkauft
bekommen sich doch bei allen
wesentlichen kandidaten durch zieht also
selbst bei der bank tritt ja nicht für
revolution ein sondern für einen aus
grüner sicht relativ sanften übergang
was sind das bbe wählerinnen und wähler
die hören wollen das alles weitergeht
wie bisher
und trotzdem was verändert wird oder
wollen sie das sind ist die mehrzahl
ihrer bevölkerung würde ich schlichtweg
sein und das ist angesagt das ist ein
ganzes jahr das ist die ganze
schizophrenie die wir erleben wir leben
in einer bevölkerung die eigentlich
genau weiß dass wir mal habt spur
jedenfalls in großen teilen glaube ich
genau weiß dass wir so nicht
weitermachen können wie bisher
und trotzdem bereit ist beispielsweise
ein phänomen wie die flut bei dem ja
keiner völlig verdrängen konnte das ist
eine klima folge ist dass auch die
brände in südeuropa klimafolgen sind
trotzdem willens ist das sofort so fern
zu verdrängen und ein zweites trotzdem
obwohl wir in einem erheblichen maße
also erneuerung uns vielleicht
vorstellen müssen die grünen bereits bei
einer vorstellung von 16 cent pro liter
benzin abgestraft werden die und
übrigens auch kein mensch jedenfalls
sehr viele nicht an der normalen
verkaufstheke für fleisch bereit ist für
ökologisch gesünderes fleisch mehr geld
außerdem wiesen schizophrenie und die
hat interessanterweise die grünen hart
abgestrahlt dadurch sind die grünen hart
abgestraft und bernburg war zunächst mal
die einzige die gesagt hat ich bin
contra gegen das weiter so ich stehe
originär für erneuerung und da hat sie
interessanterweise mit dem interessanten
es slogan geworben bereit weil ihr es
seid das war ja der werbespruch der
slogan der der dz der grünen ein
grotesker spruch weil die bereitschaft
er sich bei der bevölkerung in der
mehrzahl offensichtlich nicht in dem
maße da es gibt vier bürgern hat probier
klar gesagt dieses maß an erneuerung
übrigens dann auch mit einer
unerfahrenen kanzlerkandidatin wollen
wir ersichtlich nicht und stolz das ist
sein großes erfolgsrezept für mein
verständnis hat es geschafft das
vertrauenskapital was normalerweise in
der klassischen bundesrepublikanischen
tradition von cdu kandidatin auf
kandidat also von merkel ob flasche
hätte übergehen müssen dieses
vertrauenskapital ich stehe für
stabilität ich stehe wohl keine
experimente war ein bisschen veränderung
okay das hat er ja das haben sie das in
hamburg transferiert freiheit des
internet aussehen schon wieder hell
widersprechen heftig ich glaube diese
was wählen
dafür bin ich eingeladen worden
wahrscheinlich
diese fehler beschimpfungen die sie
übernehmen von den grünen also die
deutschen sind so veränderungs und will
ich deswegen wählen sie die grünen mit
das ist jetzt ein starker zug der
kampagne auf den letzten metern ich
teile das nicht gesehen ist auch
tatsächlich an den umfragen klimaschutz
ist für die deutschen sehr wichtig aber
sie haben warten im prinzip auf eine
politische figur die diese veränderungen
mit der sie diese veränderung gehen
wollen und die haben wir in diesem
wahlkampf nicht gesehen deswegen sind
die grünen so abgestürzt ich halte die
deutschen für nicht so finde ich so
zurück wie
sie aber entschuldigung wenn die leute
sagen auf der frage welches thema ist
geschichtlich dann sagt man natürlich
klimaschutz sagt
ich hatte aber
meist unerfahrenen kandidaten deswegen
ins kanzleramt die grünen sind ja nicht
abgestürzt ich meine die grünen haben im
jetzigen parlament wenn ich mich recht
den sinn 8,9 prozent und wenn sie jetzt
sagen wir mal tatsächlich 15 kriegen was
dann ist es eine gewaltige explosion
wenn sie so wollen der der der
wählerzustimmung es keine frage das
heißt sie sind nicht abgestürzt und
laschet hatte ganz groß auf dem 7
seit 4 das sind aber die realen zahlen
wir wissen und das sind nicht
meinungsforschungsinstitute die leute
befragen und daraus nicht der maßstab
der master ist uns bewusst machen werden
nicht der maßstab sein und zu recht
nicht die gamble hat die zahlen von 15
prozent die grünen werden eine
depression sondergleichen erleben ja
eben genau sieht ja davon seien die
leeren raum nein es ist das potenzial
entscheidend es ist das potenzial aber
das potenzial ist eine waage
angelegenheit wir haben doch aber dieses
jahr schon gesehen
haben wir doch gern letzten mal gesehen
das potenzial der spd war als der stolz
der schulz zog damals startete da sah so
aus als würde die spd fast die absolute
mehrheit
ja die enttäuschung wir haben den
europawahlen dass die in wildenrath sind
die parteien alle rückläufig sie haben
alle weniger stimmen gekriegt als vorher
was sie vorhin gesagt haben dass die cdu
das schlechteste wahlergebnis seit 1949
haben wird das erlebt die cdu glaube ich
bei allen wahlen der letzten jahre ich
glaube die zweite hürde und merkel war
es ein bisschen anders anders nichts
weiter hohes letzte wahl war als er als
er gegen schröder verloren hat war das
schlechteste wahlergebnis seit 1949 soll
dann wird dann beim nächsten mal als
merkel
merkel gewonnen hat gegen schröder da
war das genau dasselbe ergebnisse mich
auch das schlecht wissen seit 49 so ging
das weiter diese sind an das würde gerne
nochmal den gibt da ein nein hätte ich
gesagt ich möchte mit ihnen gerne noch
mal den gedanken aufwärmen das geht ja
so ein bisschen alle überlegen was
könnte am ende entscheidend gewesen sein
und frei hensel hat einen interessanten
satz gesagt den ich auch hier bei paul
86 auf twitter wiederfinde er formuliert
es so warum schafft es keine partei
einen kandidaten aufzustellen der die
menschen überzeugen faszinieren mit
risen oder berühren kann tatsächlich ist
es ja so dass olaf scholz zwar die
besten werte der drei hat aber jetzt
nicht werte wie sie
ministerpräsidenten häufig haben in
bundesländern die
deutschen wählen einen kanzler den sie
nicht haben weil ja also was wird also
noch mal mein gedanke was wird am ende
entschieden haben also haben wir jetzt
monatelang über kandidatinnen kandidaten
gespräch und am ende das ist gar nicht
so wichtig oder die rheinstadt doch ich
finde es wahnsinnig wichtig und das hat
auch im fall der union trägt dass das
wahlergebnis im fall der grünen trägt
ist das wahlergebnis und es ist halt in
beiden fällen die so übel ist dann in
ihre logik die dahinter steht das ist
halt die parteien haben entschieden nach
den regeln ihrer gremien sahen wir das
schon immer gemacht die cdu hat den
ersten zugriff auf die kandidatur das
ist so diese scheibe logik so der alte
apparat dennoch mal entscheidet hier der
moses werden weil der ist nach den
soundsoviel landesverbänden und der
logik im bundesvorstand der cdu jetzt
der zwingende kandidat und in klammern
sprechen ja auch inhaltliche gründe für
armin laschet als kandidat so ist es ja
nun nicht dass der jetzt völlig
komplett unfähiger kandidat wäre aber er
wäre vielleicht nicht der beste kandidat
gewesen oder zumindest hätte man es in
der partei anders diskutieren müssen und
ähnlich war es ja bei den grünen auch da
saßen die beiden dann am küchentisch
oder wo auch immer haben das
untereinander in ihrem gemeinsamen code
sharing
space
das unter sich ausgemacht und die partie
im prinzip zugeguckt und abgewartet und
es war klar aber die frauen karte wie
habe ich ja gesagt hat gezogen und dann
war das gelaufen und also in beiden
fällen so nach so seltsamen taktischen
erwägungen ohne zu gucken wer ist denn
wirklich jetzt der überzeugenden
verkörpert das programm am besten wer
ist unser bester mann oder unsere beste
frau und das ist hängt dem club herford
jetzt als als die cdu/csu sich
entschieden hat muss ist ja sehr
deutlich personal von lucke dann kommt
er aus und dann kommt für hänsel und
dann bin ich wieder dran wenn sie es
zulassen kann paul 68 paul oft dreist
die cdu/csu sich entschieden hat und man
muss es so deutlich sagen wolfgang
schäuble explizit persönlich sich
entschieden hat dass armin laschet der
kanzlerkandidaten nicht markus söder
sein soll da hat sie völlig verkannt
dass in diesem fall und das macht einen
ungeheuren unterschied zu den bisherigen
bundestagswahlen aus die personen also
die kandidaten präferenz die
parteienpräferenz absolut ins
hintertreffen tritt in reden lässt wenn
man so in 76 gewinnt 1 helmut kohl muss
man deutlich sagen er gewinnt in realen
stimmen die wahl ganz klar er hat fast
die absolute mehrheit 48% helmut schmidt
war mit abstand der beliebteste
kanzlerin galt als der beste mann der
falsche mann in der der beste mann in
der falschen partei ehrgeiz fast als
cdu/csu kann ja er hat die wahl verloren
gegen helmut kohl bei die parteien
bindung in einem maße eklatant stärker
war als heute cdu/csu hatten kardinalen
fehler gemacht zu glauben auch wenn wir
armin laschet aufstellen ersichtlich
weit hinter dem volkstribun markus söder
werden wir diese wahl gewinnen damit hat
sich verkannt dass und sie hat immer so
ein zweites vacano wieder dazu sagen sie
haben erkannt dass die personen dass die
kandidaten präferenz die partie die
parteipräferenz legten zu einem
entscheidenden grund weil die große
koalition über jetzt fast schon zwei
jahrzehnte die annäherung der beiden
parteien spd und cdu/csu so stark
gemacht hat und laschet so wenig in der
lage war so wenig in der lage war profil
zu gewinnen das natürlich stolz von
daher als der stärkere der originär
respektable seriösere krisentauglich und
ein letzter zum dank für ihr okay
also ob sie nun ein besseres ergebnis
eingefahren hätte oder einfahren würde
ist ja noch nicht ausgemacht als laschet
kann ich nicht beurteilen und ich würde
mir das auch nicht anmaßen und ich bin
auch nicht sicher ob er habe besser
abgeschnitten hätte wenn man darf nicht
vergessen wenn jemand spitzenkandidat
ist das im wahlkampf eröffne ganz andere
weise dem scharfen wind der kritik
ausgesetzt ist das kann sein dass man
hat plötzlich gesagt hätte hätten sie
doch bloß in laschet genommen oder
gesagt hätten um gottes willen wieso
nimmt in diesen harbeck stadt frau
baerbock die hätte das viel besser
gemacht aber ich glaube eines was wir
gesagt haben wir sehr interessant in dem
zusammenhang nämlich das wahlergebnis
von 1976 als helmut kohl die größte zahl
der stimmen hatte
schröder helmut schmidt niedrigere und
hat trotzdem eine koalition hingekriegt
mit der fdp und ich glaube und das wird
das also meiner ansicht nach das
ergebnis im wesentlichen prägen ich
vermute dass die spd ungefähr bei dem 25
prozent bleibt ich glaube wird die cdu
ein stück aufrückt und wenn die cdu ein
stück aufrückt und es nicht so schlecht
ausgeht dass laschet im grunde schon am
wahlabend sich verabschieden muss dann
ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass für
jamaika koalition kriegen relativ groß
da hab ich da ganz es ist nämlich lange
nicht sicher wenn die spd ja hammer in 3
prozent oder 3 prozentpunkte mehr hat
als die cdu dann kann ich mir durchaus
vorstellen dass die cdu mit laschet und
der fdp und den grünen in der lage ist
eine jamaika-koalition hinzukriegen und
zwar vor allen dingen deswegen eben denn
wenn die fdp die die ampel koalition
macht und gleichzeitig ist es so dass
als damoklesschwert immer noch darüber
hängt irgendwie die könnten ja auch
rot-rot-grün dann werden die sich eher
für jamaika entscheiden ob man dabei wir
reden sie hinterher wenn liegt bei
ammann darf ergänzen ich will es noch
mal klar formulieren weil es glaube ich
ein wichtiger gedanke in dieser sendung
ist also stefan aust sagt wenn die union
als zweites reinkommt hinter der spd der
abstand aber nicht sehr groß ist dann
hält er jamaika unterführung mancher
denkt weingut mögliches einsatzszenario
hat ja christian lindner schon im
bundestag vorbereitet also in seiner
rede gesagt hat die bei scholz der erste
der durch sozusagen als erster durchs
ziel geht ist nicht unbedingt der der
dann auch der gewinner im kanzleramt ist
und damit hat er gesagt im prinzip ich
mache auch mit dem wahlverlierer laschet
auf platz zwei ist auf dem platz meine
koalition
arbeiten bringt das ist ja der chef der
csu landesgruppe im interview dieses
wochenende und da hat er gesagt wenn wir
nicht stärkste kraft werden dann haben
wir keine legitimation eine regierung zu
bilden das ist natürlich eine
vorbereitung für den das ist jetzt jetzt
fange die machtspiele schon anfangen
funpark nach der wahl und die csu hat ja
noch ein hühnchen zu rupfen mit herrn
asche das heißt wird jetzt wird so
langsam der boden bereitet dafür dass
die csu sagt also wir halten dich wir
tragen dich nicht mehr mit wenn du auf
uns nicht nur zum platz eins aber das
ist ja auch in der aussage
melandri und china nicht sagen gar nicht
wählen wir wollen das ist sowieso keine
regierung bilden dass keine frau
henseler hätte gern eine neue frage
wunder sagen leute wollen sie noch die
ich habe auch noch eine neue die stars
aber eigentlich zu gut das ist ja noch
viel drin die heißt wie groß ist denn
die gefahr dass die union nach der wahl
auseinanderbricht das was jetzt
angedeutet wurde es erst mal heftiger
streit darum ob man in die regierung
gehen soll auch wenn man hinter der spd
liegt oder ob man die opposition geht
also ich glaube frau mann hat völlig
recht herr söder wird nicht wird
sozusagen diesen schulterschluss nicht
eingehen und herren laschet sozusagen in
dieser konstellation kanzleramt ragen
inwieweit die cdu danach auseinander
bricht das vermag ich nicht zu sagen das
halte ich für ausgeschlossen
wird das sagen gut aber das heißt wir
müssen bei der koalitions lotterie immer
auch im blick haben was parteiinternen
passiert was innerhalb der union
passiert also innerhalb der spd passiert
wer entscheidet wer entscheidet am ende
ob es jamaika oder die ampel geht wie
soll das funktionieren
ja ich denke rennen schallt die wahl
gewinnen wird und wenn er auch sie auch
knapp gewinnen wird ist scholz derjenige
der das entscheidet interessant ist dann
noch was bei den grünen passiert
frau berg zurücktritt ich denke man kann
davon ausgehen dass ihr weg der starke
mann werden wird bei den grünen
also insofern gehört auf jeden fall in
die abwägung rhein wäre dann macht
behält oder in frage stellt die werden
zuschauern die sich scholz abrackert im
prinzip und dann wenn herr lindner der
ja die ampel nicht will wäre hier schon
mehrfach analysiert wurde der sitze ich
denke mal die werden versuchen diese
ampel verhandlungen irgendwie zum
erliegen zu bringen um dann auf jamaika
umzuschwenken entscheidet entscheidet
wer von luke lindner am ende das ist ja
das bild das wir im moment haben frei
hensel hat mit recht auf die grünen
hingewiesen also zwischen jamaika und
ampel müssen ja zwei schwenken na also
wenn laschet und stolz und weiter da
stehen und winken müssen zwei
entscheiden in welche richtung sie
laufen wie geht das dann ist ein völlig
falsches bild was momentan beschrieben
wird lindner als der königsmacher
absurdes bild zwar ist völlig
unterschlägt dass natürlich die grünen
genauso in der gleichen position wir
haben das ist das macht diese diese
entscheidung so ungemein spannend wenn
wir mal ausschließen dass es zu einer
nächsten großen koalition kommen wird
weiter dafür kann es möglicherweise
rechnerisch ausreichen was aber dann
natürlich viele viele
unwahrscheinlichkeiten mit sich bringt
dass die cdu/csu sich unter hinter olaf
scholz einreiht halte ich für
unwahrscheinlich dass die scholz spd
noch ein weiteres mal mit einer flasche
cdu kuriert ist auch eher
unwahrscheinlich also es wird und das
macht es historisch einzigartig zu einer
dreier konstellation kommen und in der
und ich halte nur zwei für plausibel
jamaika oder die ampel sind grüne und
fdp genauso und gleichermaßen nicht nur
zünglein an der waage sondern kanzler
macherinnen wir wären ja keine kanzlerin
kriegen also die kanzler macher und das
ist natürlich dann insofern schon mal
entscheidend gewisse rolle spielt die
stärke der kleine und das ist aber nicht
ganz so entscheiden ich halte eine
andere sache absolut entscheidend der
abstand zwischen den beiden ersten und
zweiten wird entscheidend sein da haben
wir eine klare niederlage wie es
gegenwärtig aussieht von armin laschet
gehen wir mal den fall durch lasche 22%
scholz 26 prozent dann muss ich leider
auf investieren dann ist das ein sturz
den es nie gegeben hat für die union
unter 30 prozent das ist ein absolut und
das mit einem neuen punkten das werden
ich freue mich auf ihre tiere werden
sozial darauf haben pläne dem ausweg der
reihe wir sehen eine achse prozent
cdu/csu dann wird er leidet am selben
tag sämtliche heute ziehen könnte und es
ist auch keiner mehr da der ihnen
auffällt das ist dann vorbei wenn es ein
ganz schmaler abstand wird und dann wird
es spannend dann haben auch grüne und
fdp eine legitimation gegebenenfalls zu
sagen wir sind aber auch willens mit
beiden zu sprechen wenn nicht und das
macht es so spannend herr söder aus
bayern sagt weil er nämlich eine wahl in
zwei jahren zu gewinnen hat und das ist
doch das interesse der csu wenn er nicht
sogar auf die möglichkeit selbst ich
werde vielleicht noch eingewechselt das
sind ja alles gedankenspiele wenn
laschet abtritt nebringen sein oder er
will in vier jahren den
kanzlerkandidaten wenn er das aber alles
was ich war ziemlich wahrscheinlich er
muss aber vor allem in zwei jahren eine
gerade die bayern gewinnen und diese war
in bayern lässt sich natürlich weit weit
leichter gegen eine hoch schwierige
ampelkoalition mit einem vielleicht dann
doch nicht so starken kanzler olaf
scholz gewinnen als bei unterstützung
eines schwachen kanzler flasche das ist
der reine egoismus von markus söder der
hier wahrscheinlich zum tragen kommt
deswegen sagt herr dobrindt schon sehr
früh hab ich halte das aber taktisch für
ziemlich unklug erstaunlich ist ja
folgendes wenn die cdu/csu das feld der
koalitionsverhandlung von vornherein zu
macht dann hat olaf scholz enorm leichte
karten dann bleibt nämlich nicht ein
anderes als eine regierung mit olaf
scholz dann kann sich olaf scholz
wechselseitig seinen koalitionspartner
aussuchen und das wird sich die cdu/csu
vielleicht noch einmal strategisch
überlegen da nicht die richtige wahl
getroffen erinnert er danke danke für
die analyse hat von locker
gibt es an entscheidenden punkten
widerspruch in der beschreibung von
einem logo ist das
ja-lager anbetrifft und wer ähnlicher
meinung wenn man sagen aber wir wissen
ja uni wies tatsächlich ausgleichen wie
ein ende ab das gericht
wenn es nicht je höher der abstand also
je höher das ergebnis für scholz desto
höher wird die fdp werden
desto kleiner werden die grünen das ist
ja also sozusagen je schwächer laschet
als merkel innerhalb der lager die
vivendi die lager werden die bewegung
findet ja nur innerhalb der lager statt
je besser das ergebnis für scholz und
umso besser das ergebnis für lindner was
bedeutet dass die grünen dann am ende
bei 12 prozent naja das als keine
ergänzung oder vielleicht bei der scp
noch ich sind gar nicht unter das was
für ihn gesehen haben als
in diesem plan ausschnitt laschet dafür
plädiert hat nicht die ard zu wählen hat
natürlich einen enormen hintergrund wenn
wir uns an die an die verschiedenen
wahlen von schröder
erinnern da hat im grunde die
linkspartei eine ähnliche funktion für
ihn gemacht mit umgekehrten vorzeichen
wie jetzt die afg für die cdu erinnern
sie sich bei der zweiten wahl als
schröder nicht in den irak krieg
miteinbezogen werden musste da hat er
die wahl dadurch gewonnen dass die af
der dass die linkspartei unter fünf
prozent war das war der ausschlaggebende
punkt dafür dass er die wahl gewonnen
hat und als als er die wahlen vorgezogen
hat da ist ja frau merkel im grunde nur
deswegen kanzlerin geworden obwohl die
eine ampel hätten machen können weil die
linkspartei im parlament war und zwar
über die fünf prozent gekommen ist und
lafontaine ist im grunde derjenige
gewesen der frau merkel zur kanzlerin
gemacht hat denn weil der aus der spd
aus waren die linkspartei sind die über
fünf prozent gekommen wenn die unter
fünf prozent gewesen wären dann wäre
schröder wahrscheinlich kanzler
geblieben das heißt die nehmen der cdu
unglaublich viele stimmen weg das darf
man nicht verkennen die atb la vela
werde sich alle
ideen die in vielen stimmen wir müssen
wissen also wenn die wenn die
tatsächlich nachdenken sollten müssen
sie wissen der fdp
hilft eine rot-rot-grüne koalition oder
auf eine ampel zu machen das war ja
argument per alleingang noch mal
erläutert danke franz ich würde ja noch
mal auf einen lindner schauen ich glaub
nicht dass der in der zwangslage ist
dass er jetzt unbedingt in einer ampel
gehen muss sozusagen weil wenn er nicht
in der ampel geht dann ist er zum
zweiten mal hat er nicht regiert oder so
ich beobachte diese druck lage nicht ich
denke dass er tatsächlich eher an
glaubwürdigkeit gewonnen hat dadurch
dass er einmal gesagt hat ich schmeiß
das hin aber das haben ihm zwar viele
sehr übel genommen aber es hat ihn
natürlich auch die glaubwürdigkeit im
respekt gegeben dass er außen diesen
verhandlungen auch wieder aussteigen
könnte wenn er sagt ich bin nur das
reichen blatt hier mit dem stolz und ich
bin nur der wasserträger dann für zwei
linke parteien für die ich irgendwie in
der koalition da muss ich dann eine
kröte nach der anderen schlucken muss
also ich weiß auch dass auch seine
anhänger ihn ja auch bestellungen sogar
auf gar keinen fall dürft ihr irgendwie
da diesen linken partnern mit denen ins
bett legen also da gibt es eine sehr
starke strömungen bei den liberalen die
sagen um gottes willen da lieber doch
wieder opposition das heißt sie heißt es
für möglich das ist lindner ich hab so
wirklich dass seine ampel sprengt und
dass er auch in die opposition geht
absolut ich würde gerne da unsere
sendezeit sich dem ende neigt und wir
aus gutem grund heute überhaupt noch
nicht über inhalte gesprochen haben
jedem und jeder von ihnen jetzt ein
mögliches bündnis nennen und sie bitten
jeweils wirklich in einem satz einen
gedanken zu sagen was verändert sich
damit frei hensel sie dürfen wählen
zwischen ampel jamaika rot grün rot oder
großer koalition zu welchem der
bündnisse möchten sie mir die frage
beantworten was verändert sich ich
glaube eine ampel koalition ist nach
diesem verkorksten wahlkampf gar keine
so schlechte regierung eine ampel wird
eine märkische tonalität weiter haben
scholz ist sozusagen
das steht für das kontinuum dieser
dieses dieses jahr dieser märkischen
politik
wird für klimaschutz sorgen müssen auch
das muss scholz in die regierung
integrieren um sven lindner sich in
zukunft so ein bisschen mehr modernen
und zeitgemäßen liberalismus bekennen
wird dann kriegen wir gar nicht eine
schlechte regierung aber was erwartet
uns bei der ampel danke jetzt haben sie
noch die auswahl zwischen micah
koalition nicht gut aus das entscheide
ich ja auch nicht im endeffekt sie
helfen zu areal wasser also ich glaube
das wirkliche problem dieses wahlkampfes
ist dass wir im grunde drei mehr oder
weniger sozialdemokratische parteien
haben die gegeneinander antreten und
sehr ähnliche wahlprogramme verkünden
also die cdu die spd und die grünen und
das ist sozusagen das erbe von angela
merkel aber was im endeffekt bei welcher
koalition rauskommt dann muss ich sagen
das passiert mir fehlt mir jede fantasie
okay dann frage man halte mich freuen
wenn die alle der realität man ein
bisschen näher kommen wieder andere
frühe
einsatz noch ich würde wirklich
widersprechen dass diese drei parteien
total ähnlich sind also da auch wenn die
union waage sachen ihre gramm ist aber
dass die alle dieselbe rolle das ist
dieses mal nun wirklich nicht so ich
sehe es allerdings auch wie sie das ich
mir fällt jetzt auch da müsste ich
wirklich kaffeesatzleserei betreiben
aber ein gedanke vielleicht die wirklich
großen reform wurden ja immer von denen
gemacht von dem man es gerade nicht
erwartet hätte absolut ruhig rot grün
mit hartz4 zum beispiel das heißt was
ich mir vorstellen kann ist dass zum
beispiel eine neue große koalition oder
vielleicht ein jamaika-bündnis noch am
meisten klimaschutz sozusagen durch
pusht viel mehr als eine eine ampel oder
das umgekehrt von einer ampel wer weiß
dann steuererleichterungen in großem
stil aus ist man weil die fdp dort er
auch ein geschenk kriegen muss oder auch
im thema durchbringen muss danke herr
von glocke welches bündnis wählen sie
zur antwort auf die frage was 83 naja
ich eben den letzten aspekt haben wir
jamaika und ampel gehabt rot rot grün
hat deswegen unter schließt und das ein
bisschen an was frau ammann andeutet an
hat deswegen auch wenn es inhaltliche
schnittmengen im sozialpolitischen
bereich gibt auch im klimapolitischen
bereich es hätte gar keine chance gegen
einen absoluten bürgerlichen block mit
dem begriff bürgerlich wenig
problematisch finde aber einer absoluten
gegenwehr von cdu csu und fdp die sich
wie über gefundenes fressen her machen
würden gegen ohnehin eine eine schwache
rot-rot-grüne konzeption die nicht stark
wäre in der in der prozent sei das heißt
er ist braun ich muss nur punkt machen
die sendung gibt es ein ende mir ist mir
ist hängen geblieben sie gucken wenn ich
die balken aufrufe vor allem wie groß
der abstand zwischen rot und schwarz ist
das kann entscheidend sein
und mir ist hängengeblieben herr lindner
muss vielleicht am ende doch gar nicht
so dringend mitregieren die wir denken
danke für ihr interesse hier in der ard
das europamagazin bei wdr 5 jetzt
presseclub nachgefragt danke dass sie
dabei waren schönen sonntag und lassen
sie diskutieren
[Musik]
der regierung sind der muss regieren
nachgefragt lesen ja sag ich denke hier
am tisch läuft lebhaft weicher das ist
gut so jetzt sind sie aber dran und wir
beginnen in
tettnang bei gabi angele guten tag liebe
frau angela willkommen in der sendung
sie haben das wort guten tag auch einen
schönen guten tag an die runde ich
wollte folge das erwähnen ich kann
einfach nicht nachvollziehen dass wenn
fdp cdu und csu vor den kameras ständig
sagen dass sie keine steuererhöhungen
haben wollen dann müssten doch die
entsprechenden medien sofort
unterbrechen und klar machen dass es
nicht um steuererhöhungen generell geht
sondern um steuererhöhungen prinzipiell
für superreiche millionäre milliardäre
petra so wie sie zum beispiel von der
spd oder den grünen oder linken
gefordert wird und das mit recht denn
die fdp und cdu/csu
die sollen doch mal erklären wie diese
die infrastruktur bildung schulen klima
finanzieren wollen da hört man von
diesen parteien gar nicht ich bedanke
mich gut vielleicht ein statement von
der frau am 1
sie sind sehr präzise fragen gedanken ja
dann folgen wir gerne ihrem wunsch oder
also wir haben ja schon glaube ich dass
öfters geschrieben dass es in der tat so
ist dass bei der union ein bisschen dass
das konzept fehlt wie man denn dann
gewisse kosten die der staat hat
begleichen soll
also ich
glaube die zuhörerinnen völlig recht und
widerspricht auch hinaus die programme
der parteien sind sehr unterschiedlich
wir werden das in den
koalitionsverhandlungen sehen man weiß
nicht so recht worauf sich zum beispiel
eine ampel scholz habeck und linda
tatsächlich einigen wollen man ist in
den fragen von steuererhöhungen komplett
konträr man ist in der frage der
schuldenbremse durch den durch einen
durch eine investitions regel zu
erweitern völlig konträr also dass sie
haben völlig recht doch vielleicht weil
sich freuen ich habe gerade eine kleine
entlein blackout die union bei denen ist
das ja dieser hoffnungswert dass wenn
steuersenkungen gibt dann wird die
wirtschaft entfesselt keine rasse das
geld in die kasse also stichwort trickle
down economics es ist hat ja nun doch
mehrmals in der geschichte nicht
hingehauen das konzept aber das ist der
hoffnungs werk unterschiedlich neue
inhalte volkswirtschaftliche debatte ok
danke die wollen wir nicht weiterführen
sondern mit christian werthmanns in
geldern willkommen über die kroko
nachdenken fährt man es ja vierten runde
meine frage ist eigentlich joghurt wie
was kann ich dafür eine große great
können auf welchen kannst du auch immer
wie wahrscheinlich ist dass es eine
große koalition gibt der mark dazu das
ist relativ einfach zu beantworten wenn
die zahlen stimmen dann ist es denkbar
also ich würde auch nicht total
ausschließen dass die cdu wenn sie
haarscharf hinter der spd liegen sollte
und das zusammen reicht dass sie bereit
wären eine große koalition zu machen
würde ich nicht total ausschließen also
ich glaube am wahlabend wenn sie die
zahlen vorgelegt haben dann beginnt ein
ganz neuer denkprozess und es könnte
sein dass wir dann plötzlich da sitzen
und sagen wenn wir das jetzt gewusst
hätten dann hätten wir eine ganz andere
diskussion geführt eine frage verändert
die situation gewaltig
der inhalt ist für ausgeschlossen und
auch ich halte es aber umgekehrt gut das
hat die spd und schon häufiger
verspannung ja zum vierten mal in folge
das ist
gut die frage die ich auch mehrfach
gelesen habe hier ist wie lange sich die
koalitions verhandlungen hinziehen
können ob es sein kann dass die
neujahrsansprache schon von einem neuen
kanzler oder einer neuen kanzlerin
gehalten habe ich wetten würde ich
wetten ich bin ziemlich sicher dass die
jetzige kanzlerin die neujahrsansprachen
noch halten
ok dann müssen wir noch den wetteinsatz
flasche rotwein
dass sie in der ersten sendung des
jahres die debatte am tisch die
wahl gewinnt zieht sich daraus eine
koalition und wünsche die wahl gewinnt
auch wir gehen davon aus dass die beiden
sich so quasi auf den füßen herum stehen
werden ich halte das für eher
unwahrscheinlich wir geben die koalition
gehen und weiter ist zwei materials oder
in seelze in niedersachsen wenn ich das
richtig sehe schon da lag ja das ist
richtig vielen dank an die vielen dank
dafür ich und meine frage stellen darf
oder vielmehr ein internes sich dabei
sind ja danke ich glaube was insgesamt
bei ihrer wahl etwas übersehen wird ist
das thema
alter in unserer gesellschaft ich glaube
wir tun uns weil wir eine sehr
verhältnismäßig eine gesellschaft und in
europa auch unglaublich schwer mit
veränderungen und
das ist auch etwas was vielleicht auch
jeder für sich je älter wird auf
feststellt dass er dann auch bei dem
bleiben möchte was erkennt und diese
veränderung wie ja auch von den grünen
natürlich doch völlig zurecht kommen im
bereich des klimawandels und so weiter
in veränderung die ja vielleicht auch
maschinen leuten angst auslösen und und
weshalb man auch ja das mit kleinere
übel von allem weg und das ist in meinen
augen oder
vielen dank ich finde den gedanken
spannend wir haben ja vorhin so weiter
so oder feind herumgesprochen helfer
luke ist das ein kampf jung gegen alt in
den bell absolut es ist vor allem auch
ein brutaler objektiver kampf für
denjenigen der noch zehn jahre muss mal
ganz hart fast lebens ökonomisch
betrachtet für den der noch zehn jahre
zu leben hat 20 jahre oder 30 ist die
rechnung eine andere als dem der noch 70
jahre zu leben hat und von daher ist
interessanterweise ob er umfragen die
frage gestellt worden wie verhalten sie
sich eigentlich an ältere gerade ältere
ist die bereitschaft da zugunsten der
jüngeren also echte thema politische
änderungen zu tätigen sie ist in hohem
maße nicht daran dass dieser neue
objektive generation ihrer enkelin ein
erstes haben nicht erst sie haben nicht
alle erstens haben nicht alle hacken
klemm es gibt ja sehr viele die keine
kinder haben und leider muss man vorher
nie widersprechen wir häufig findet rand
das ist doch sympathisch aber trotzdem
da wir haben ja schon ein schönes duell
aber das mag ist es trotzdem bemerken
sind und für mich ganz interessant dass
bei einem goodwill von terence for
future etc die diskrepanz der
lebensverhältnisse der älteren auch
zulasten der kinder denn sie haben alle
durchaus kinder bisher noch nicht so
einschlägig ist dass sie begriffen
hätten wie dramatisch die klimakrise die
chancen ihrer kinder beeinträchtigt
deswegen ist das wenn wir ja lebens
müssten ja die grünen versuchten jahr zu
realisieren
schreibt euren eltern einen brief ist
dass
guttenberg er solche bälle gibt das wird
ja zum teil delegitimiert die seit
dieser dieser versucht dann auch von
eltern zu sagen gebt eure stimme
sinngemäß den kindern übrigens open oder
die jüngeren müssen deswegen auf meine
sache absolut über ein wahlrecht ab 16
jahren reden mindestens ab 16 jahren
diese debatte ist eine hoch wie rowland
und wir werden auch nach der wahl
natürlich große auseinandersetzung der
jüngeren haben die sich fragen geht das
jetzt weit genug das ist übrigens auch
als letztes sein und diese natürlich
sind das un-gericht grundiert das
letztlich genau das auf fordert wir
müssen eben die einschränkungen heute
bieten und damit könnt ich spreche immer
dass wir bei nachgefragt keine debatten
führen aber ich bin trotzdem kurz ihren
widerspruch hören der
generationenkonflikt den wir jetzt in
den zahlen sehen ist ein ergebnis des
grünen wahlkampfes die werbung kann die
natur hat vor drei herausforderungen
gestanden die wechselwähler zu bekommen
die alten zu bekommen und den osten zu
gewinnen war ein recht und darin das
sind genau die zahlen die
in den blick immer vorne lang das hat
sie nicht geschafft dass die grünen
jetzt auf den letzten metern mit diesen
enkelin briefen versuchen im prinzip
eine eigene schlappe des wahlkampfs zu
kaschieren zeigt nicht dass die
generation derart gespalten ist es die
werbung ist keine kandidaten für die
eigene sind nie gewesen bei claudia bis
koubsky guten tag willkommen in der
sendung schön dass sie dabei sein
herzliches hallo aus berlin ich würde
die frage
in die runde interessieren mit ihrer
meinung wie groß die gefahr einschätzen
dass jetzt gerade kurz ein paar tage vor
den wahlen und auch noch direkt vor den
wahlen durch zum beispiel internets
durch viel oder falsche informationen
oder durch einseitig gezielte
informationen noch mal versucht wird
bewusst im wahlkampf einzugreifen
und ich stelle die frage ich mich ohne
weiteres hätte genau zu diesem thema bei
phoenix einen bericht dazu gehört und
gesehen und noch lieber empfinde ich
kombination wahlkampf so emotional und
noch nie waren durfte wieder nicht
entlocken also wurde mich wirklich ihre
meinung dazu meint ruinieren ja danke
ich weiß nicht einmal das thema ist voll
im gang das problem ist in vollem gange
werden viele berichte darüber bei uns
auch unter anderem dass
der grünen zentrale die überschwemmt
wurde fünf tage lang mit anrufen
irgendwie weil es sie im internet
kursierte die grünen wollten die
haustiere verbieten wir wollten den
leuten verbieten haustiere zu haben und
dann ist halt so eine doch eher noch
kleine parteizentrale komplett
lahmgelegt weil die leute anrufen und
sich beklagen und also das heißt dieses
diese desinformationen die sind im gange
die betreffen aber auch nicht nur die
grünen muss man sagen zwar im besonderen
maße die grünen aber richten sich
natürlich auch gegen die union und
andere es ist ein massives problem aber
man hat natürlich sofort wenn man da
jetzt ruft danach dass irgendwer
regulierend eingreifen soll das problem
dass natürlich dann auch dinge
ausgeblendet werden könnten oder
reguliert werden könnten die einfach nur
teil des politischen meinungskampf sind
also da bin ich insofern zurückhaltend
jetzt da in irgendeiner weise
kontrollieren
gewaltig verändert seitdem jeder im
internet seine meinung sagen kann das
was früher in der kneipe gesagt worden
ist und sich nicht weiter für hätte die
kneipentür verbreitet hat das ist jetzt
alles im internet und das kann man nicht
das kann man nicht verbieten und ich
finde wenn jeder wählen darf dann darf
jeder seine meinung äußern auch wenn das
manchmal sehr unerfreulich folgen hat
übrigens wie beim wildau interessant ist
dass es den wahlkampf am ende auch nicht
so stark beeinflusst hat
man angst haben könnte bist du
vielleicht nach einer ganz thema
bistritzky die ich wird das also ich
erlaube mir auch mal zu antworten es
gibt zum wahlkampf trump gegen clinton
eine interessante auswertung der uni
berkeley die zu dem schluss kommt das
ist zwar wahnsinnig viel fake news und
überspitzte post gegeben hat dass die
aber ganz überwiegend die jeweils
ohnehin schon überzeugten erreicht haben
und deswegen die auswirkungen
wahrscheinlich überschaubarer war als
man das damals geglaubt hat ist fünf
jahre her gibt die parteien reagieren ja
auch sehr schnell auf diese vier jungs
mit eigenen kampagnen mit
richtigstellungen und so gut hoffen wir
hoffen wir dass es genug es nicht
professionelle und seriöse medien gibt
die das dann glaubwürdig aufklären
können bedanke mich und gehe weiter nach
nümbrecht im oberbergischen nicht weit
von köln entfernt timo haller hat uns
angerufen hallo ihr hammer
runde meine frage ist einfach ob ich die
stärke der anderen partei gegenüber der
cdu ist dass viele leute sagen noch
einmal vier jahre cdu ist das schlimmste
was man wählen kann
naja hab ich das sehr ich glaube in der
tat dass dieser wahlkampf natürlich sehr
stark dazu dadurch beeinflusst wird dass
wir eine kanzlerin hatten die 16 jahre
im amt gewesen ist und das ist jetzt der
erste sozusagen richtige wechsel der
stattfindet und die cdu hat ihren ihren
markenkern verändert das kann man
positiv oder negativ sehen und laschet
verwaltet sozusagen die die merkel-cdu
kann kann nicht auf contra gehen kann
aber auch nicht so sagen weiter so
gleichzeitig ist die spd
auf dem weg schon das kann man schon
daran sehen dass herr scholz mit der
raute auftritt zu versuchen sozusagen
die beständigkeit der regierung merkel
weiter zu propagieren also insofern ich
glaube das ist wirklich sehr wichtig und
auch für das denken der leute dass sie
gesagt haben nach 16 jahren muss jetzt
irgendwas anderes kommen wie sie es
wissen alle nicht so richtig was anderes
kommen sollte und ich glaube in der tat
dass problem das wir haben auch was die
kandidaten selbst anbetrifft ist ein
teil auch ein resultat von 16 jahren
amtszeit ist ja nicht nur eine person
dirigiert sondern ganz so hoch stadt
regiert hier für eine so lange zeit und
das glaube da geändert wird danke mich
und gehe weiter von nümbrecht nach
hirschberg an der saale roland barwinsky
ist am telefon bitte schön herr winski
ist ja hallo verstehen die mich sehr gut
klar und deutlich wunderbar also mich
treibt ihre eines unfalls so viele
analysen geben und es wird
wahrscheinlich eine große diskrepanz
geben zwischen den wahlergebnis der
grünen in west- deutschen
universitätsstädten unter usd quasi in
ostdeutschen ländlichen regionen zum
beispiel in sachsen wo sie dann
besonders boxen und da hab ich manchmal
den eindruck dass nur in zwei
verschiedenen welten leben und dort in
ein land und ich bin ja gespannt wie das
neue
golf ist diese band diese
verschiedenartigkeit der religiös quasi
zu ende bringen will das würde mich mal
interessieren wie das gelingt könnte
er von lucke darf ich
sie haben als erste wort und dann darf
man hier widersprechen sie haben völlig
recht
wir sehen in diesem wahlkampf von
austausch und zwei phänomene
interessanterweise wird werden große
teile des nordens des ostens sehr rot
also die aus deutschen wollen ist normal
mit einem sozialdemokratischen kanzler
probieren offenbar bei wir sehen vor
allem in sachsen aber auch in teilen
thüringens dass die afg wahrscheinlich
stärkste kraft wird
und im moment wenn man diesen wahlkampf
im osten sich anschaut dann wirkt er
eigentlich friedlich die fds politische
eingehegt die gesellschaftlichen
konflikte jedoch sind es nicht und sie
können sich immer wie ein streichholz
neu entzünden und ich bin gespannt
darauf was ein wahrscheinlich kanzler
scholz mit einem posten macht mit einer
fd die jedes neue thema nutzen wird um
sich wieder stark zu machen die
konflikte tatsächlich werden jetzt mit
einem kanzler scholz ja auf einer
inneren er in der sozialen frage
diskutiert werden müssen und nicht mehr
anhand der achse von konservativen des
rechten einstellungsmuster insofern
seien völlig recht es wird sehr
interessant werden wollen sie ergänzen
wir sind ja sie haben recht ich weiß gar
nichts mehr sagen eine koalition mit
einem kanzler um die 25 prozent das wird
er in jedem fall sein ist eine andere
als eine zweier konstellation als eine
dreier konnte sein völliges novum mit
einem wahrscheinlich nicht sonderlich
ausstrahlung starken kanzler weder jobs
noch laschet sonderlich visionäre typen
dh hier werden enorme fliehkräfte weit
über den osten aus bringen sich die
schwierigkeiten schon in der koalition
drei disparate parteien zusammen mit den
bei fliehkräfte in die gesellschaft die
viel dramatischer sind merkel war bei
vieler kritik lange zeit dann doch so
etwas wie ein dach der anker ihre werte
sind immer noch erstaunt bedanke mich
auch bei handball linz geht der
hauptunterschied ist übrigens die städte
wo große zuwanderung ist die stadt grün
sind und die landstriche wo starke
abwanderung ist die daneben starr kfd
sind danke für den aspekt noch danke
ihnen für die muntere debatte 'ran
schönen sonntag aus können vielen dank
an sie
[Musik]